realismus ist eine sache
naja was bedeutet das es ist die praxis
eine situation so zu akzeptieren wie sie
ist und die bereitschaft zu haben
entsprechend mit ihr umzugehen
der film lucky erzählt von einem mann
namens lucky einem alten mann 90 jahre
alt und lucky hat nichts mehr zu tun in
seinem leben außer eben die tage hinter
sich zu bringen die ihm noch gegeben
sind und für diese tage hatte er ein
sehr schönes ritual wir sehen in den
ersten szenen an einem typischen morgen
[Musik]
trotzdem muss er sich dem gedanken
stellen dass er irgendwann sterben wird
und das ist das thema des films lucky
die vergänglichkeit des menschen die
vergänglichkeit eines alten mannes und
davon erzählt lucky auf eine sehr
angenehm zurückhaltende weise aber warum
zum teufel bin ich umgefallen weil sie
betrunken nein wird ihnen öfter
schwindelig ich hab doch gesagt wir
waren nicht schwindelig bewegen sie sich
auch genügend ich auf die ganze zeit in
der gegend rum und macht jeden tag fünf
yogaübungen viele philosophische themen
werden angesprochen werden aber nicht
über gebühr ist dem zuschauer
aufgedrängt ihr kommen allein auf die
welt allein gehen wir auch wieder
erleiden das dann trostloses wort es ist
wunderschön du sagt eine besonderheit
des films lucky ist dass der mann der
die hauptrolle spielt mit der figur
lucky im film eine menge zu tun hat
harry dean stanton war selber 90 jahre
alt als sie diese rolle gespielt hat im
vorjahr ist er verstorben
das heißt er hat das wovon der 14 auch
selber erlebt und man denkt jetzt wenn
man ihn sieht im grunde auch immer an
ihn als schauspieler einen der
bekanntesten amerikanischen darsteller
seiner generation
[Musik]
es gibt leichte anklänge an den western
harry dean stanton hat eben in vielen
western gespielt man spürt hier in
dieser landschaft eben auch noch dass
das immer noch eine rolle spielt zum
beispiel ein bestimmtes ethos der
unabhängigkeit und erhält eben auch bis
zum ende es in seiner autonomie aus ein
mann der seine tage auf eine sehr schöne
weise zu bringt und allmählich dem tod
näher kommt und uns damit auch einen
film schenkt er uns selber ganz egal wie
alt man selber ist dabei hilft sich ihre
gedanken eben einzuüben
dass die ndf live bands wie man sie
macht auf irgendeine weise irgendwann
gegenstandslos sein werden und man dann
eben das ist nichts schauen wird von dem
lucky unser wenn es sehr schöne weise
ein bild gibt das uns trösten kann und
dass uns etwas über das leben auch lärm
kam
ich kenne die wahrheit und nur die
wahrheit zählt das ist eine sache
richtig
ja die wahrheit ist eine sache es ist
die wahrheit darüber wer wir sind und
was wir tun
dieser tatsache müssen wir uns stellen
und sie akzeptieren ja weil die wahrheit
des universums auf uns wartet und davon
abgesehen ist der film natürlich ein
großes dokument ein großes vermächtnis
dieses bedeutenden amerikanischen
schauspielers harry dean stanton
sie waren sehr brav reutte deshalb wegen
sie so ein
und was soll ich damit tun wir nach
stecken wenn sie weniger süß haben
wollen